fifty-five the FBI compiled a 2,000 page
file on Albert Einstein acting on
suspicions linking him to Soviet
espionage activities next author Fred
Jerome details the bureau's activities
his new book the Einstein file spells
out how the bureau spied on Einstein and
his associates and identifies some of
the informants who said he was a spy he
also explains the pacifist and socialist
politics of the author of the theory of
relativity which mr. Jerome concludes
was the driving force behind j edgar
Hoover's efforts to discredit Einstein
this history on book TV discussion is 35
minutes thank you there are besides
Frances golden my agent and her
associates Adele Cramer who couldn't be
here tonight and Michael Dennin a my
editor extraordinaire there are many
people here tonight and I'd like to
introduce but not now I hope do hope to
do so later because I think we should
get on with the reading and discussion
I'm honored and you're all fortunate
tonight that helped me with the brief
reading that we're going to do my dear
friend Gwen Simmons has agreed to take
part so if you in to welcome her I won't
give you four wonderful skills that she
has
the this reading focuses on just one of
many possible aspects of the book
afterwards the floor will be open for
questions with more questions and
comments welcoming later and on the
website www.rinaldin.com uggs posters
and calendars yet nowhere in all this
Einstein yeah will you find his comment
to the Chaney Records student newspaper
of a small black college in Pennsylvania
quote race prejudice has unfortunately
become an American tradition which is
uncritically handed down from one
generation to the next
unquote also missing our remarks
Einstein made to the Atlantic Conference
on anti-racist of anti-racist educators
ten years before the civil rights
movement quote every right minded person
will be grateful to you for having
United to fight this evil that so
grievously injured the dignity and
repute of our country also missing from
the t-shirt scene Einstein statement
that quote racism is America's worst
evil during the last 20 years of his
life
Einstein almost never spoke at
universities he considered the honorary
degree programs to which he was
frequently invited to to be ostentatious
moreover his declining health made it
difficult to travel so he simply adopted
a just say no rule but in May 1946 he
broke that rule to speak at Lincoln
University in Pennsylvania the oldest
black university in the world both the
year and the school are significant
here's how
one of Lincoln's students described
Einsteins presentation writing in the
student newspaper the Laconia they
linked cone Ian and I just like to say
that I am very honored to be sharing
these moments with my dear friends Fred
and Jocelyn here's how one of the
lincoln students described einstein's
presentation in the lincoln tone Ian on
Friday May 3rd a very simple man came to
Lincoln University his emaciated face
and simplicity made him appear as a
biblical character quietly he stood with
an expression of questioning wonder upon
his face as president Horace Mann bond
conferred a degree then this man with
the long hair and deep eyes spoke into a
microphone of the disease racism that
humanity had in the deep accents of his
native Germany he said he could not be
silent and then he finished and the room
was still later he lectured on the
theory of relativity to the Lincoln
students and later that night Albert
Einstein went back to Princeton
to understand the full significance of
Einsteins presentation at Lincoln and
its miniscule covered coverage by the
mainstream media we need to recall the
racial situation in America and what
might be called the bloody spring of
1946 in the wake of World War two a wave
of lynchings had swept across American
by within one year after Hitler
Mussolini and the fascists had been
defeated 56 black Americans had been
lynched in this country most of them GIS
would return from fighting for democracy
in Europe the mainstream media missed or
ignored many of these murders but on
July 27th 1946 a front-page story in The
New York Times which Einstein read every
day reported one of the more gruesome
cases and lynching in America suddenly
became national and international and
unavoidable news
from the New York Times Georgia mob of
20 men massacred two Negroes wives one
and xgi this is dated Monroe Georgia
July 26 two young Negroes won a war
veteran who served in the Pacific and
their wives were lined up last night
near a secluded Road and shot dead by an
unmasked band of 20 white men the Negro
men were taken out of the car first and
led down the side road the women were
held in the automobile then a member of
the mob said that one of the Negro women
had recognized him get those damn women
to the mob leaders shouted and several
of the men then dragged the shrieking
women from the automobiles the story
also reported that the victims had been
shot at least 60 times and that the
bodies were scarcely recognizable
because of the mass of bullet holes two
days later the Times reported close
relatives of two of the four negroes
killed by a white mob here on Thursday
failed to appear at funeral services
today and Friends voice the belief that
they were too frightened to appear a
grand jury heard testimony from 106
witnesses in this case and then returned
no indictments
it's impossible to imagine that Einstein
was not shaken by these news reports
when in early September a telegram
arrived from Paul Robeson inviting him
to serve as co-chairman of a group
called the American crusade to end
lynching the group would hold a mass
rally in Washington on September 23rd
the anniversary of Lincoln's
Emancipation Proclamation the protests
to be led by black veterans would demand
punishment for lynchers and prompt
passage of a federal anti-lynching law w
eb Dubois and other prominent leaders
black and white were also on the
delegation to Washington co-chairman
Einstein was too ill to attend but sent
a letter with the delegation to
President Truman declaring that security
against lynching quote is one of the
most urgent tasks of our generation
the overwhelming majority of people
favored security for all against illegal
violence and there is always a way to
overcome legal obstacles whenever there
is an inflexible will at work in the
service of so gesture caused twelve
pages of the FBI's Einstein file
concerned the American crusade to end
lynching considerably more pages than
most of his affiliations perhaps that
was because Hoover and his bureau viewed
the anti-lynching campaign much as they
would later view the civil rights
movement of the 1960s as a threat to
America's security here's one typical
reference in the Einstein file to the
anti lynching crusade quote the crusade
has all the earmarks of another
communist attempt to instill racial
agitation Einstein's FBI file reports
that he endorsed not less than 12
anti-racist civil rights organizations
including the defense of the Scottsboro
nine
and lesser-known but just as unjust
frame-ups against Sam Buchanan Willie
McGee Rosalie Ingram and the Trenton six
in February 1951 the historian and civil
rights activist w e BD boys was indicted
by the federal government as a foreign
agent for having set up an organization
called the peace Information Center the
photo of this renowned black historian
in court in handcuffs was flashed around
the world as one more example of
American racism and McCarthyism the case
against Dubois was thrown out by the
judge before the defense had a chance to
present its case but the first defense
witness for Dubois was scheduled to have
been Albert Einstein for having the
audacity to be both black and red Dubois
and ropes and faced a double-barrel
assault from the US government perhaps
more significant than Einsteins
affiliation with any single civil rights
group was his solidarity with these two
world-renowned figures Robeson and
Dubois especially his enduring
friendship with Robeson we don't really
have enough time to read the summary
from the book of robsons outstanding
achievements as the Renaissance man we
all know that he was but excerpting
again from the book between watching
Robeson and watching Einstein Hoover's
agents were able to report on a number
of their collaborative subversive
activities such as support for refugees
from the Spanish Civil War and support
for henry wallace's independent camp
for president in 1948 so in addition to
these activities and the American
crusade to end lynching in 1946 Hoover
was able to garner quite a bit of
so-called information but Hoover seems
to have missed the most important
episode of the einstein-rosen story as
the Cold War heated up Robson became
perhaps the most hated target of
McCarthyism in America besides having
his passport taken away and constant FBI
surveillance and harassment he was
vilified in the media almost daily by
the early 1950s if you read their
headlines and listen to news broadcast
anywhere in America you might have
thought the unbending bass-baritone was
public enemy number one
in spite of our more likely because of
that atmosphere Einstein decided to
invite Robson to visit him again it
inviting him in 1947 to at the start of
the Wallace campaign to visit him again
in 1952
Einstein's invitation was a definite act
of solidarity remembers Lloyd Brown a
writer and Robson's longtime friend and
colleague Braun who is due here tonight
I don't know if he said he's here
where is he okay it's here tonight and
accompanied Robson on the visit to
Einstein's house in October 1952 here's
how a rope stern letter described the
visit it was good once again to clasp
the hand of this gentle giant recalling
our previous meetings when I'd appeared
there in Princeton and concert and an
end in Othello
dr. Einstein asked about my life today
as an artist and expressed warm simple
the with my fight for the right to
travel we chatted about many things
about peace for dr. Einstein is truly a
man of peace about the freedom struggle
in South Africa which interested him
keenly and about the growing shadows
having cast being cast over freedom of
thought and expression here at home
though he is physically frail and not in
good health one can feel the strength of
his spirit and the glowing warmth of his
compassion and his humanity there was a
note of deep sorrow and concern
underlying his comments and what is
happening in our land as he spoke one
could sense something of what this must
mean to Einstein the giant of science
and culture who was driven from his
homeland by the Nazi barbarians and who
felt the immeasurable tragedy that his
people suffered at their hands the two
men obviously enjoyed each other's
company
at one point when Robson left the room
Brown remembers trying to make
conversation by saying hmm dr. Einstein
it's it's really an honor to be in the
presence of such a great man
Einstein's response with just the touch
of annoyance was but you came in with a
great man that's that's the end of the
reading
we can have time for some questions that
microphone you have any any questions
that's good you'll forgive not a
question but the comment you're entitled
I was a student I was a student in New
Orleans during the Vietnam War period
and active in the anti-war movement and
a pamphlet came from North Vietnam to
our peace group and it was authored by
Ho Chi Minh and he was talking somewhat
autobiographically about how he came to
be revolutionary and he mentioned that
he was a merchant marine in his early
early years and he visited many ports
around the world and he visited New
Orleans in about 1919 or so I forget the
exact date and he says he was shocked to
see in the New Orleans item a newspaper
and now it's called or the later called
it was called a States item but at that
time was called a New Orleans
item he said when he arrived in port he
found the newspaper saying there was
going to be a lynching later that day
and and you know the implication was
everyone was invited and he was just
shocked that they would have something
like that in the paper not reporting on
something that had happened but that was
going to happen and and I said to myself
reading this thing this is impossible as
this just can't be so being in New
Orleans I took myself down to the public
library and checked out the microfiche
of the of the paper and he was
absolutely right so you know obviously
lynching goes way back and this was a
show as a kind of continuity in the
story of lynching in America a little
off the wall perhaps but
math your music just reminded me of that
incident there's a there's a sequel to
that story in in the book which they
won't give all the details up but in in
nineteen in 1946 there's an interview in
the Chicago Defender the same day that
the ropes and delegation to Washington
had a confrontation with Truman and was
not a pleasant confrontation you will
read but that day there was an interview
in the Chicago Defender by by George
Padmore renowned correspondent black
correspondent with a foreign leader
described as the head of quote a little
country seeking independence unquote in
the interview the foreign leader
criticizes lynching in America as quote
barbarism and events Vince's quote great
concern about the status of American
Negroes and any surprising knowledge of
the American situation accompanying the
interview is a large photo of a foreign
leader of the foreign leader a young
handsome brown skinned man with
intensely focused eyes his name is Ho
Chi Minh and his little country seeking
independence is ganam other questions
don't feel compelled funny yes question
my name is Bob Marsh my memory sort of
failing I think I know Fred for about
six months
he's render I haven't read the book yet
but I was impressed by the title and
also the cover and and some people may
have heard the phrase that the internal
is primary but that doesn't that doesn't
hold true necessarily for books it
certainly holds true for your health and
your body I want to congratulate Fred on
his book and I have a lot of things on
my plate right now on dirty dishes
laundry and two other books and I hope
one day to read this book I actually
broke down spent some money to buy the
book and just congratulations Fred and I
hope that you have many more titles and
as I always say you can't tell the
contents of the book a book by its
contents thanks thanks for the Frankie
thank you the question okay Julie can
she go I can move then I'll go to that
night
this is this is somebody else I've only
known for in your research did you do
much research on Hoover himself and his
bite them and the biographies of Hoover
as as referring to Albert Einstein yes
yes and there there is a good deal in
this book of who about Hoover although I
have to tell you I took most of it out
there are other books about Hoover that
you can get some very good ones I would
love to write more about Hoover I think
he is he's one of the truly writable
about characters and in the history of
the world and the story of of his visits
to New York every weekend when he went
to the racetrack and then went to the
store club afterwards and hung out with
the Mafia at the tables and if their
photos of all this so it's just
wonderful stories it has really not a
whole lot to do with the Einstein file
although everything is connected and I
do have some references to Hoover where
I think it's relevant but certainly a
good topic let me let me well are there
other questions well while you're
thinking of questions I'd like to
introduce a few people who are here and
maybe then other questions that just
there are so many people here who have
helped in in so many ways with the book
that it's impossible to even begin to
introduce everybody but I did mention
Lloyd Brown and I'd like you all to meet
him even though I wasn't sure that he
was here at the time so Lloyd it would
you okay
and
as you you heard the story about his
visit to to Einstein and if you get a
chance to corner him during the evening
you can hear a lot more stories and
there's some wonderful stories a couple
of them are in the book but there are
others that are not and I highly
recommend it
another important person who helped with
the book and plays a role in the book is
dick Rowan glass who's here who's the
son of William and Tilly found glass and
I don't know areas over there the the
photos in this book include a photo
which he took at the age of 13 of his
parents with Einstein when Einstein
invited them to the Einstein home from
Brooklyn after his father had been fired
from his job as a teacher by the Board
of Education and Einstein had written a
letter to his father which they agreed
would be a letter sent to the New York
Times and was printed on the front page
of New York Times as an open letter
really urging intellectuals to refuse to
answer questions from the committee and
it it became a story across the world
now in Bartlett's quotations and dick
was kind enough not only to discuss the
letter with me but when they left
Einsteins house his mother asked his
father to pull the car over to this I
told his father to pull the car over the
side which he did and immediately took
out paper and pencil and told everybody
to write down their their memories of
what had happened and those notes he
kept he kept in his possession not
showing them to anybody and until he had
a chance to show them to me and I was
able to wheedle them out of him no he
was very very generous and sharing those
notes and I think they they add
something to the book
thank thank you
I'd also just like to briefly mention
Robert Schulman who's here who was the
former head of the Einstein papers
project and and contributed something to
the book and Alice Calla price who's the
editor of the quotable Einstein and the
expanded quotable Einstein and I highly
recommend Anna and and a book coming out
in the fall called dear dr. Einstein
Richard children's letters dine sandwich
I wish very much I had written but I'm
happy that Alan Alice wrote and that
it's coming out and and thanks also to
Frank Serpico for coming and I wish we
had a chance to hear some of your
stories maybe we will and so okay and
aside from people whose names you might
know there are lots of people whose
names you might not know but who have
fought the good fight
for years and Eddie Weiner
that's that Leonard who's here many
others who have in their own way fought
that fight and many of the younger
people who were here today I am really
honored that they that they took the
time to come and I see that many of them
are have taken the difficult but but
immensely wonderful challenge of
starting families and I like to think
that they that they would have done that
even if they had known about Einstein's
1800 word file in the FBI so with that
if there are no more questions what
there are questions please yes we've
known each other for a while and you
know that my wife and I are scientists
and Albert Einstein was an inspiration
to me
ever since I was a young budding
scientist one of the things I wanted to
point out is one of the things that
inspired me about Albert Einstein was
that he was a Zionist and I think it's
important to point out that he debunks
quite clearly that awful myth that was
created years ago that Zionism is racism
because he was clearly a Zionist and a
profound anti-racist in my book I do
have her section all about a large
section on Zionism because it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't prominent in the FBI
file for variety of reasons but and it
is true that Einstein took many
positions on Zionism over the course of
years
initially he did not support the
formation of the State of Israel wasn't
formed until left and didn't support
until after it was formed even then he
was critical of the leaders many of the
leaders of Zionism had his fallings out
or had his differences with them
primarily over the issue of Arabs
there's a little-known letter to
Weitzman which I quote took Haim
Weitzman who was the founder of Zionism
which I quote in the book which says if
we do not succeed in finding the path
amana's cooperation and coming to terms
with the Arabs we will not have learned
anything from our 2000 year old ordeal
and we'll deserve the Fate which will
befall us
he also said in 1952 my relationship to
the Jewish people has become my
strongest human bond and I think it's
important to understand Einstein was a
complex figure this is not a simple
person and had a variety of different
points of view so I thank you for
bringing the subject up I don't it's a
much longer discussion of course before
closing one more two more two more oh
well I bet one of the few advantages of
being old is that when I was in college
we protested correctly all of the
specific lynchings that you mentioned as
well as the legal lynching later on and
in 1946 my two brothers went on that
crusade to end lynching and one of them
was killed on with it in a car accident
yellow bus vote and the interesting
aspect of Einstein is that the publicity
the whole policy there wasn't a
mainstream press were attacks on robson
but they never mentioned that Einstein
was a co-sponsor
if she took it
I haven't read the book yet either but
just from the excerpts that you given
today and from the information that I've
gotten either from you um over the last
few weeks uh I realized that this book
is um very important to be included and
in schools and I wonder what you're
doing in terms of meeting with school
board members since I used to be on a
school board or meeting with people in
schools so that this dispute aside the
version that was totally silent um it
can be presented and so young people can
be aware especially apropos of what's
going on today in the silence and the
the difficulty of getting information
and how easily people can be vilified
because of the lack of information I
think this book is critical and timely
and I hope but are you gonna put it and
do something about getting it into
schools
as a as that lady used to say can we
talk uh I just I wanted to that a lot of
people haven't read the book which means
we should have another party after
you'll read the book and have come back
but there's one person here who who has
read the book more than once and and I
at least one well no one person here who
has read the book more than once and not
only read it but contributed to it
edited and is in many ways that the
godmother of the book and I would like
to end by introducing her and in it
although she said she did want to say
anything ask her to say a couple of
words and that's Dorothy zelner my
friend for longer than I like to
remember
I have to tell everybody this is my
oldest friend
I was seven when I met him he is six and
and he's learned something in between
this is the person who was my teacher
who I owe a tremendous amount to and I
always told him the book has to be
written this is an important book so I'm
very happy to see all of you and I hope
we share that it is an important book
let's go and enjoy the food and and even
though they say that books book parties
don't sell books here you're entitled to
buy some this about it yeah one more
question I Fred I mean we all know some
very popular things about Einstein that
he wrote the famous letter to Roosevelt
advising the building of the atomic bomb
and he was against the use of atomic
energy after the war and his offer
becoming president of Israel but why is
so absent this attention to his civil
rights almost unknown until until this
book why of why of Einstein's politics
been kept so little-known a short
question the longer answer but I would
just tell you the story that I was at I
was I was at a meeting with the some top
scientists recently and a leading Nobel
Prize winning physicist leaned over to
me and he knew about the book and he
says Einstein was a pinko
and I said I said you know I said why
are we whispering
I'll give you that that's the
Fred Jerome is author of the Einstein
file J edgar Hoover's war against the
world's most famous scientist it's
published by st. Martin's Press online
at st. Martin's comm next week historian
Bach TV features the hidden hand richard
Aldrich's story of the Cold War through
the prism of covert intelligence
gathering between the US and England if
you're interested in finding out about
the author